with a franchise ruining sequel / reboot
on the horizon it's time to celebrate
the 30th anniversary of the fool you
loved as a child of the 80s or the
cartoon you loved is a child of the 90s
or the theme song you sort of recognize
as a child of today who you gonna call
ghostbusters before Harald Ramos passed
away
Bill Murray became a professional party
crasher and Dan Aykroyd went batch crazy
I don't think we will ever have a formal
relationship a formal contact with any
alien species out there especially after
9/11 they were the Ghostbusters
old-looking out of touch out of shape
nerds
when we get to 20th tell me I'm gonna
throw up
yep this is what movie stars look like
in 84 kids when there's something
strange in your neighborhood there's
only one group of unlicensed heavily
armed disgraced college professors you
can call the Ghostbusters ghostbusters
what do you want there Spangler a nerd I
collect spores molds and fungus ray
under if the ionization rate is constant
for all ectoplasmic entities we could
really bust some ads in a spiritual
sense of course Venkman a borderline
sexual predator can we stay here in bed
talking back
and Winston who's supposed to be played
by Eddie Murphy but got more or less
written out of the movie when he passed
on the role and eventually cropped out
on home video 2 when ghosts rise from
the dead to haunt New York the
Ghostbusters are the only thing between
the city and total chaos causing the
media to run glowing profiles of their
successful business instead of the fact
that ghosts exist in our haunting New
York but it's nothing that Ghostbusters
can't handle they got the car the
gadgets and the vaguely scientific
know-how to put evil in its place 10
people witness a free-floating
full-torso vaporous apparition actor
plasmic residue complete particle
reversal total protonic reversal focused
non-terminal repeating phantasm
four-fold cross rep you have been a
participant in the biggest
interdimensional cross trip since the
Tunguska blast of 1909 felt great I'm
pretty sure you made half of that stuff
up slide down the fire pole and into a
PG rated movie that kids loved even
though it's full of cursing oh I have
seen that'll turn you white what in it
this man has no dick casual smokey
boob grabbing
and ghost head
whoa kids movies were way better back in
the day
so grab your stick stick heat him up
here I make them hard and don't cross
the street across the strings as the
ghostbusters take down the best knobs
the 80s had to offer you are a cool
scientist dr. P exactly what are you a
doctor of $5,000 I have no idea to be so
much I won't pay it and imprison
hundreds of innocent creatures who don't
do much besides read eat drive and uh I
feel so funky I feel like more of the
taxi let's say booze starring William
Murray me funny Dan Aykroyd Egon would
not forgotten you sick horny Weaver
eighties dick young old Larry King
flubber dark helmet David Bowie not
Eddie Murphy fat Casper the dad from
family matters and ron jeremy whoa no
way
ghostbusters kids this was called a
library it's like a printout of
Wikipedia where you have to be quiet be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers chicken nuggets ate my homework
what's crack-a-lackin' it's Saturday
Night Live I got
nipples some days you just can't get rid
of a bomb fuzzy pickles Wubba lubba dub
dub